and we're gonna do our draft today based
upon the best
weapons so far of the 2020 season no
quarterbacks we're talking about weapons
it could be defensive it can be
offensive just weapons just however you
want to use that phrase
weapons chris you've got a trivia
question for me i understand my vikings
fan card is on the line with this one
yeah but i don't have the question so i
may have
i may have burned it after sunday's game
just so you know so i may not want it i
mean that's the thing
do i if i get it wrong do i have to keep
it is that where it stands right now
keep your eyes right here you ready
don't look down there don't look down
there okay
all right justin jefferson 100 575
receiving yards on sunday we're third
most ever by a vikings rookie
we know second was randy moss with 190
yards at green bay in that great game
when he was young
who holds the vikings rookie record for
receiving yards
in a game receiving sammy white yeah you
knew that one easy huh
yeah that because that's right in the
wheelhouse of when i was a kid
right and yeah sammy white was great
sammy white was awesome
uh just as i suspected you
are a lifelong vikings fan
but here's the thing live or die vikings
fan your team
i was 10 years old in 1976 um
i was 11. wait 76 that was the year they
went to the super bowl yeah i was 11.
okay good um glad you know what else age
you were
yeah yeah thanks uh i really i really
can since i got it right can i turn it
in can i rip it up i i
i life is a hell of a lot and i kind of
like the fact
because even though i've been in this
business 20 years now there's still
and i think anybody who's in this
business you don't get drawn to this
business because you didn't like
football
you're drawn to it because you like
football and it's impossible to like
football without having a favorite team
yeah and the challenge has always been
setting aside
that thing that brought you here and
being neutral and objective and i think
i've done a good job of hell i criticize
the vikings more than anyone
i agree but when they stink the job's a
hell of a lot easier
and with each passing year i i care a
little bit less and a little bit less
but this year i can tell you i don't
care at all and frankly for getting that
right
i would like to have the opportunity to
trade in my card i don't want another
one i just want to enjoy the game i want
to enjoy the players i want to enjoy
great games i want to get excited about
watching a game that goes down to the
wire and watching great talented players
do their thing
so that leads to today's draft the best
weapons and without question without
question and
chris i agreed with you and i may have
co-signed with you
on the wisdom of trading deandre hopkins
from the texans of the cardinals but
good lord
the guy's got 32 catches in three games
yeah right
michael thomas was talking about
breaking his own single season record
for receptions at 149 that he set last
year
hopkins is on pace to do it what he's on
pace to have over 160.
he's got 32 in three games it's
incredible yeah
and uh it's one of the most overlooked
stories of the season so far
because we got blown away by what
happened week one but he's continued to
do it every week
he's the guy the kylie murray keeps
finding ways to get the football to in
er
they are high percentage passes um you
know it's not like he's throwing it down
the field 40 yards
so he's going to keep getting these
completions and the numbers are going to
keep getting racked up and he's helped
that offense
tremendously he he really has he was
going to be my first pick too so i mean
i'm in agreement with you there
yeah that mean yeah i thought there was
a chance that
watson might be better off not having
hopkins being wide receiver by committee
and
i'll be the first to tell you i was
wrong been proven wrong already i threw
in the white towel with tony dungy
last week i said you're right it's over
forget it the texans offense
doesn't know how to work by committee
and arizona's showing
it knows how to folk you know focus on
one guy and make him a guy
and then it helps everybody else out and
you know to the way it's looking right
now it looks like the texans operated
better that way too but he's been great
what's that let's say yeah let me just
say this real quickly
this is an example of why the coach in
the gm should not be the same person
because the texans needed someone to
talk bill o'brien out of that trade
and bill o'brien the gm was unable to
talk bill o'brien the coach out of the
trade period all right you're up yeah
that's uh
it's valid i hear you there uh you know
after that i mean when you just talk
about best weapons of 2020 so far
i mean this guy might be number one
really
that's dk metcalf i mean that's the guy
i'm going with there i mean just
yes physical freak deep balls
you know just a like a difference maker
as far as
what defenses have to do and be wary of
where he is on the football field that
way and we just see
big catches and big moments all three
weeks
i mean he is no doubt one of the best
wide receivers in football
yeah i agree and that would have been my
first choice if you had gone deandre
hopkins if i had gotten that question
wrong so i agree with you it's
tremendous
what he's done he's averaging almost 100
yards a game he's got his three
touchdowns he would have had
four if he didn't showboat near the end
zone he's probably learned a life long
from that he's been incredible all right
now there's so many a lot a lot of
different directions and
and i'm torn between a pair of running
backs i'm gonna go with clyde edwards a
lair okay
because of what he's done to the chief's
offense you know the numbers aren't off
the charts
he's he's among the leaders in rushing
but
uh he's diversified that offense to the
point where as we said yesterday
you get locked in you get focused you
get white-knuckled you're ready
to try to stop tyree kill and company
and
they hand the ball to clyde edward
zelaire and you know they gain seven
yards or they throw a little swing pass
to him and they gain 15.
and that balance to the offense makes it
so much more dangerous
and so much more potent and uh that
that's been that's been a a great great
find for the chiefs and a great
complement to what they already could do
yeah agreed it is it's changed their
football team i mean now he throws balls
like short and you go oh he's only gonna
get two or three yards and he gets six
yards or seven yards or it's oh i run up
the middle and there's nowhere to go and
he gets
two or three yards like those that that
adds up
it really does especially for a great
offense like that i i think i got to
stay at running back too
i mean i gotta go i'm gonna go with
alvin kamara i mean
crap what we've seen out of him the last
two weeks holy
crapola i mean really you talk about a
guy that
you know we talk about all the time guys
that can deliver more than what the
scheme
offers you right i mean yeah that scheme
suits him really well
but damn i mean when you run down the
sidelines and bounce off seven guys and
break four ankles and spin and run for
touchdowns and run through the middle of
the line and break a tackle
and cut back and cut back the other way
i mean he's been unreal
again he goes back into that
conversation mike it just shows you when
you pay guys
right and they feel like now i'm okay i
can let it fly
i feel like we've seen an uptick in his
performance just because of that he
knows there's no more worry
i don't got to protect my knees going
through the hole or my ankle
i've been paid i'm good i can just go
pedal the metal and he's been fun to
watch
yeah that was the next guy on my list i
i'm going to go back to receiver
uh not because the numbers are off the
charts although they're impressive but
stefan diggs
and he's not on your vikings anymore
yeah justin jefferson that's my guy too
i like it replace him yeah but but
what what diggs has done has been great
not just from the standpoint
of production but from the standpoint of
opening up the offense making it easier
for josh allen and he's
extremely unselfish that's one of the
things alan told me after the game
on sunday he doesn't say throw me the
ball he says make the right decisions
if i'm open give me a chance but make
the right decisions
that's what the quarterback's supposed
to do throw it to the open guy
or more importantly to the most open guy
on both of tyler cross touchdowns
stefan diggs was also open tyler croft
was more open right so you throw to the
guy who's the most
open and the first guy to go
congratulate tyler croft
with stefan diggs unselfish player
opens up the offense helps josh allen
reach an mvp level oh and without him in
minnesota
all of a sudden kirk cousins isn't in
that conversation for one of the best
quarterbacks yeah
no i know you know i mean to me i know
it wasn't like perfect and you know
better roses up there in minnesota all
that but
he he acted appropriately he could have
been a lot worse i think we could
we would have seen other receivers up
there and some of those moments go
like a little bit more bat crazy than
than stefan diggs did
we're almost we're almost at the at the
point though where after that week four
game
remember he disappeared from two days
right yeah i mean yeah
yeah that was as bad as it got it did it
worked it worked and he didn't say
anything even though
he kind of yes disappeared i feel like i
got to give like one defense a guy love
in this draft all right
i just got it as much as i want to go
another offensive guy and do all that
all right obviously aaron donald is the
best defensive weapon in the game so no
disrespect to you aaron donald i'm just
trying to show a little love to the rest
of the football world
i mean chris jones is the guy i'm going
to go with i hate picking another kansas
city chiefs guy just because you picked
one but
again you know i don't even know what
the stats say for what he's doing right
now
all i know is i watched that baltimore
ravens game the other night and he was
around the running backs and lamar
jackson
all game long and he's like that every
week
he is other than aaron donald the most
disruptive interior defense alignment in
the game
and even has such an effect too mike on
plays where
you know yeah we talk about f the play
up and all that stuff
but also the his ability to bat
footballs downs how many times i watch
in a game where a quarterback's going to
throw and they pull it down because
his big paws are up in the air and now
they have to readjust
and it leads to bad things so i'm going
to give him some love because he
deserves it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports